غضب تركي في وقت لفت اعتبرت الحكومه
التركيه تعليق بعض انصار حزب العمال
الكردستاني دميه مسيئه للرئيس التركي في
العاصمه السويديه استهداف خطرا يتنافى وفق
وزير الخارجيه التركي مع تعهدات سابقه
للسويد في اطار سعيها للانضمام لحلف نيته
[موسيقى]
بامور ضمن قدرتهما ووقعتها على ذلك ونحن
نطالبهما بان يلتزم بالوعود التي اتفقنا
عليها لا اكثر المنظمه الارهابيه مستمره
بوجودها وفعالياتها هناك وهذا ظاهر ليس
عبر جريمه الكراهيه التي نفذت بشكل واضح
الامس بل عبر الفعاليات الداعمه للمنظمه
الارهابيه وتامين العناصر لها وجمع
الموارد الماليه والحملات الترويجيه
هي اذا وفق المسؤولين الاتراك جريمه
كراهيه تقتضي تدخل الحكومه السويديه التي
استدعى سفيرها في انقره والغى رئيس
البرلمان التركي زياره رسميه كانت مقرره
لنظيره السويدي الى العاصمه التركيه وزير
الخارجيه السويدي توبياس بليستروم اصدر
بيان ادانه حادا اللهجه للحادثه مؤكدا
تفاهم بلاده لرد الفعل التركي الغاضب
واسفها في الوقت نفسه لالغاء زياره رئيس
البرلمان السويدي قال بيان الخارجيه
السويديه ايضا ان المنظمه المسؤوله عن
الفعاليه المسيئه اعلنت صراحه ان الغرض
كانت تخريب طلب السويد الانضمام لحلفته
معتبرا ان العمل الذي وصفه بالوقح يخاطر
بتعقيده وتاخير العمليه التي بداتها
السويد وحالي فيها المستقبليه في نيته
تركيا في اجواء حرب اوكرانيا تعطي السويد
ومعها في لندن اهميه بالغه الانضمامهما
لحلف النيته ويشترط لهذا الانضمام او
اعضاء الحلف على الموافقه ومنهم تركيا
التي قالت سابقا انها ستقبل بشروط وصفت
بالامنيه تتعلق بنشاط عناصر حزب العمال
الكردستاني في البلدين قبل ايام اكد رئيس
الوزراء السويدي ثقه بلاده في موافقه
تركيا على طلب الانضمام للنيتو لكنه اشار
بالمقابل لعدم القدره على الوفاء بكل ما
طلبه الجانب التركي في الاثناء تفائل امين
عام الحلفني بانتهاء عمليه انضمام السويد
في لندن للحلف هذا العام مبديا تفاهما
للموقف التركي ومشيرا لان تركيا هي اكثر
الدول الحلف تعرضا لهجمات ارهابيه